today's topic someone sent me this from
a youtuber who's all the way out in
korea megan moon so as we know korea is
very different from my home country of
the usa america and through marriage
i've also learned a little bit more
about some differences that we have and
the way that we view relationships and
the way that we go about them etc so i
thought i would talk today about some
things that i learned from being married
here in korea the very first thing that
i learned was that marriage is duty and
it's quite different from like kind of
what we see like in the hollywood and in
media and stuff
what
yeah
that's actually why most of marriages
fail you think it's just it gets better
after you get married you're just gonna
cruise there and everything will be fine
i'm married now
[Music]
and you realize you got some work to do
the word duty is an interesting one how
do you define duty
it's work that you got to do
yeah it's the work that you got to do
in order to maintain something it's a
duty and you get into this thing with
someone else you have a duty the other
person has a duty you sign them up you
have a duty to make it work a moral or
legal obligation a responsibility
now people hear obligation when it comes
to things like marriages and they're
like there should be no obligations in
relationships you signed the papers for
what boo-boo you made the vows you made
the vows you signed the paper you signed
the paper there was a priest involved a
pastor there was there was witnesses you
got two witnesses you got uh on on both
sides you come on now
and after that you got all this [ __ ]
going on you have the same you have the
same elements you have the same
[ __ ] elements as when you go to
court you got someone that prosecutes
you got witnesses you got to sign
[ __ ] paper and you got your
sentence for life
and then you think there's not going to
be work
[ __ ]
and by the way when i appreciate it like
when i say [ __ ] i'm not talking to you
megan i don't know you but i don't know
your thing it's not you i'm just talking
in general yeah let her preach
let her preach yeah
god man go on megan and i feel like kind
of our view of marriage like in america
is a bit more romanticized it's like
it's romantical kind of disney kind of
fairy tale type thing that we like view
with marriage i feel like sometimes we
lose a lot of the duty and a lot of
people in mayor just think about you
know the things that they want to get
like i want to get married so i can get
this and i can get that and i can have
love and happiness and stuff like that
but i noticed in a lot of asian
countries like they view marriage as
duty of course you know people love each
other like when they get married but
there's more of an aspect of the things
that you need to contribute and things
that you need to do in the relationship
to keep it afloat and i notice when
people think of marriage here they think
less about okay what am i going to be
getting like give to me give to me and
there's less of this sort of entitled
feeling for what you think you should be
getting in marriage everybody thinks
that marriage is like
50 50.
you hear that often it's not 50 50.
it's a hundred a hundred
you give a hundred percent of you i give
a hundred percent of me
it's not fifty-fifty
it's not that's a lie
that's a whole lot of lie and whenever
sometimes i'm gonna be at 90
you're gonna give 110 or even sometimes
120.
[ __ ] think it's 50 50. it's not
and people tend to focus on how they can
make it work and the things that they
need to do within that marriage and one
thing that i notice is instead of people
getting their happiness from what
they're getting like i'm happy when my
partner is doing this for me or when i'm
getting this love or when i'm getting
the things i feel like i'm entitled to
get is people feel more happiness in
knowing that they fulfilled their duty
in marriage
we moved
we moved to the condo right
you said you should have seen my chest
you should have seen one no no no no no
no
you need to take this 10 steps back to
give the context
why that move was a big deal i know why
they won't understand so you need to
explain a little bit about the financial
situation prior and what it meant for
you to contribute so that they can get
the full picture of why your chest was
like this
because i don't remember [ __ ] you came
in one day and your head was like this
i was like what happened
i thought you turned into a final
fantasy characters but
so give him everything please i'm gonna
tell you this right for the first few
for the first few years of our lives uh
i was making more money to her because
she was it's cool
i i've decided to say
[ __ ] this
college [ __ ]
i'm out
i'm gonna go in the world and work
she went to school did her thing she
applied in a job
and
it went good first few years i was
making more bucks and more bank than her
i was switching job and stuff like that
and then
she gets promotions
promotions
promotions at some point [ __ ]
was asking me so what does your girl do
i was like [ __ ] i don't know you know
why cuz i don't need to know because she
going about to get a promotion in
[ __ ] three weeks so i
so [ __ ] knowing what she does she always
[ __ ] switches on me [ __ ] that [ __ ]
and at some point for the good part of
our life she was making
two
to three times my bread
so
since i'm not the bread bread winner
now i gotta i gotta cope with other [ __ ]
i gotta fix [ __ ]
i gotta you know i gotta i gotta
sometimes
i gotta do some [ __ ]
long hours so whenever she would come
back home i'd have to make the dinner
like you get the you know i mean to hold
my own i had to bring my 100 percent
right
right because she was bringing her 100
right you know i mean
and then
this [ __ ] happens we doing good we doing
great [ __ ] about to buy the condo but
then i'm able to i'm about to to get him
back
to be like nah put it on the car
now i got this
that's a real [ __ ]
oh no put it on the card
i got this
so it felt good for you to be able to
provide the space that you guys were
going to yeah
yeah it felt like you were able to
fulfill your duty yeah it was like yeah
duty that's the thing and i was but it's
just
i just got it i got i i got this goal i
gotta you know
and i still feel like i gotta i owe her
you know that's pretty much it because
all those years she had my back i gotta
get back on it now it's my turn let me
get my let
yeah well i mean just just just to just
be able to you know
okay you know whenever
you're in debt to somebody that's not
really what it is but imagine that
you're in debt imagine you're debt into
somebody and you're finally able to pay
it boom yeah i'm talking about
respectfully not throwing in someone's
face i'm talking like yeah here you go
and then you add interest and you're
like yeah we good and then cool i got
you
getting someone's back
after they happen after they have yours
you pay some shits to your parents and
stuff like that
i'm like yo this pandemic is happening
and i was talking to my mom's like yo
you [ __ ] are gonna go to miami
this year it's like uh we don't know
because we can only fly and i was like
yeah i'm gonna fly you there i'll fire
you both for you i'll fly you there
first class yeah but what about the car
we can't run the car i'll send it there
send me the bill
[Laughter]
it's a duty so whether it is with your
wife whether it is with your parents
what it was with my sister i got my
sister's back
do you know what i mean
so that's what it is and i think that's
something that's actually really nice
because you can't really control what
other people do right you can't control
like if someone's gonna do something for
you that day but you can't control the
things that you're doing and i think
when your happiness comes from
a sense of fulfillment for doing the
things that you're supposed to do to
keep the marriage running then i feel
like that leads to much longer happiness
as opposed to just what can i get what
can i get what can i get can i just take
a second to appreciate how wise that was
she said
if your sense of fulfillment and enjoy
comes from what they do for you then
it's kind of out of your control whereas
when you get joy and pleasure from being
able to give others and it's always
something you can choose to do each day
so there's something that's very nice
about it oh no megan megan is on point
yes she's spitting game right now we
wasn't talking [ __ ] about your wife mr
moon we showing her some love yo yo
maggie megan spending some sense right
now yeah
so let's compare like marriage to like a
business or something right
so for a business to run well
the employees should always be doing
their job if the boss said
you know what you can just work when you
feel like it and everyone only worked
when they felt like it instead of what
you have to do every day then the
business might not go so well and so i
feel like uh with marriage is similar
like you don't always feel like doing
things that you're supposed to do all
the time but that's just kind of part of
it and this is just a very light example
it's the only thing that just kind of
pops into my head right now but this is
not something that moon said i need you
to get me my coffee every day but it's
just kind of something that i like to do
in the morning is to make mr moon coffee
sometimes i don't feel like getting his
cafe latte in the morning but i know it
makes him happy and it makes it keeps
our marriage going and when he sees that
i'm getting up to get him his cafe latte
even if i want to be sleeping in it
makes him happy too and makes him want
to keep doing things you know for me so
we just keep giving to each other and
each other and each other and we
continue to
like thrive in that way
i did that's my girl bought her a coffee
a coffee machine she likes to espresso
in the morning no she likes a coffee
latte and for three months the first
three months i was getting up i don't
have to get up she wakes up at six five
six in the morning i wake up to get man
get her coffee but but but but but but
whenever she's in the kitchen she's like
yo i'm playing playstation yeah you want
a sandwich
yo go in the kitchen make me a sandwich
no
i don't have to ask
i don't have to ask you know why
because i give her coffee because she
don't have to ask
the [ __ ] that have to ask their
wife to make them a sandwich y'all
losing to me
that's that's a l to me i don't even
have to ask because she don't even have
to ask for the coffee
i'm not even saying i'm perfect i think
but it's a dynamic guys let me know in
the comments below but this is not the
video in which preachers preach the most
it just may be
my nigga's going in i mean mrs moon is
going in as well yo
if you have to tell your wife that was
the whole thing with the meme world you
know how i am with me does the whole
thing about yo go in the kitchen make me
a sandwich yeah okay honest to the joke
and everything and stuff but if you have
to ask
let me just say uh one thing that i
think she said that was very mature she
says some days i don't want to do it but
i still do it during the truth about
relationships
sometimes you don't really feel like it
but it's still your duty to do it and
the other person's also supposed to
reciprocate in that way as well you know
this whole idea of like only one you
want to enthuse yes no
sometimes you don't want to get up to go
to the gym shut the [ __ ] up and you find
the duty to go
you still have that responsibility
that's it you got a ninja yo what's up
one time for me for missing miss moon
boom boom yo
how many times do you think that man
wants to go to the hospital zero but he
has a duty when he's in a marriage to go
to the hospital why because he has to
manage his health to be around we all
have to do [ __ ] we don't want to do
and another thing that i noticed is
those feelings of love
tend to stay and continue to happen when
both people are fulfilling their role in
doing their duties in the marriage
things work out that you put effort into
i don't know if that makes sense i hope
it did take from what you want so the
next thing that i've kind of learned to
do here is i've really learned to
embrace the differences between men and
women i feel like sometimes in the west
we like to ignore that there are
differences between men and women but i
feel like here in korea people
understand that there are differences
and it doesn't mean that one is better
than the other but they don't demonize
any characteristics that are inherently
masculine or feminine my girl
my girl to this day
we had the conversation the other day me
and my girl
i said to my girl it's not to diss
anybody it's really not it's really not
it's really not
i asked my girl are you a feminist
my girl said no
i'm like why don't don't you don't you
want to be equal
i'm like we are equal
but i ain't putting out the goddamn
garbage that's your job
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's your role
and i win
that's my job
[Music]
people allow for people to play to their
strengths especially in relationships
and i think that's something that's
really nice and the beauty of it is
you're not necessarily bound to the
expectations that people have of this is
man and this is woman society is not
saying you must have traditional
gender roles but if you want to do that
people don't seem to demonize you where
i feel like sometimes in the west now i
mean i was like that like i remember
when i was in high school about to go to
college i had a friend and all she
wanted to do was just get married and
have kids and she wanted to have a lot
of kids so she did that right out of
high school i remember kind of judging
her like ew why would you do that you
have no ambition so then i kind of like
really stopped talking to her because i
thought oh my god what is that like why
would you just want to do that and like
live with a man who makes the money and
do that like be independent have some
ambition and stuff like that was kind of
how i used to think about women who
wanted to do that but one thing that
korea has taught me is that you know
everyone like chooses what they want to
do if a woman wants to take on a
traditional role and that's what she
wants to do then we shouldn't tell her
she's wrong for wanting to do that you
know i think we should be able to choose
what we want to do and people shouldn't
look down on people who want to do those
traditional roles in that way i used to
be one of those people who looked down
on women like that as i was going to
college getting my degree that i'm not
using at all in debt not anymore but
wasn't debt she ain't got no debt and
she got like four kids and she's happy i
see her on instagram so oh and growing
up too like my parents were always like
yeah be independent do this like don't
depend on no man don't eat no man and
now that i'm married i'm like i needed
him where have you been mr moon okay
where have you been like why didn't i
meet you you know if i hadn't met him
when i was 22
he might not have liked me because mr
moon my husband he likes to feel like
needed and at that time i was kind of
like anti-anything like i don't you know
help no man mr mood he loves like
carrying things and like doing things
and just being helpful and i think in
the past like old megan would have
thought like oh it's because he thinks i
can't do it i can do pull-ups weighted
pull-ups 20 pounds strapped to me i can
do a pull-up i don't need you to carry
my bags
why why is she why she turned why didn't
megan turn into
cardi
because that's probably how she wasn't
the thing that happened is like i'm
gonna tell you okay but yeah now i'm
like yeah i can do it but
one thing that i've noticed about men
one of those inherent traits that men
have is they like to feel needed and to
feel as though they're helpful and
they're contributing is one of the
things that drives them to want to do
more and do better so i noticed with mr
moon i could get him to do more things
more chores by saying oh yeah you know i
really need your help the last time you
did it you did it so well it was just so
amazing is that
we don't want a boy
we got boys already
i could chuck this beer bro
i could do okay i got boys to do that
too
sometimes i want a girl sometimes that's
my [ __ ] girls
yeah you could do it i it's not because
you can do it that it's good i could
drive my car with my feet that don't
make it a good [ __ ] idea who said
that
chris chris rock
chris rock said that
yeah
um
great video first stop shout out to her
yeah listen anything that encourages
people to take up their responsibilities
and their duties and understanding that
life is about work it's about labor then
i'm always for and you know
to extend this past dating and marriage
i had someone who was in university
asking me about potentially dropping out
and what he thought and i told them this
whatever you choose in life understand
it's going to come with its
responsibilities and there's a lot of
labor that you're going to have to put
in this whole self-employed life this
whole dropping out to be an entrepreneur
it's not just you don't go to school you
don't pay no bills you just get a job
it's like no there's labor that you have
to do there's hustling that you have to
do there's effort in that you have to
invest in this thing
so coming in with that mindset is going
to help you understand that it's not
glamorous and
self-self-employed hours and you get to
work when you want to work and
everything is no it's honestly super
draining and taxing but there's a reward
to it but you need to understand
it's
labor
that's what it is friendships
relationships marriages uh work
relationships even this it's labor
marvel you see us laughing
behind the scenes it's a lot of labor so
anything that encourages people to
understand those responsibilities to
embrace it and to see the positive in
that i'm all
for so shout out to mrs moon and that
was my thought on that what did you want
people thought about
oh
uh do a job that you like and you'll
never work a day in your life that is
the worst [ __ ] i've heard
the real saying is not that the real
saying is get a job you love
and you don't know when you'll stop
you'll always be working that's really
what it is yeah right yeah yeah there's
no schedules to this [ __ ] yeah the
dream job is not the fact that there's
like an absence of labor it's not
absence of work
there's no dream job there's no job
where you don't have to do [ __ ] you
don't want to do
you want to be a youtuber [ __ ] you
better learn how to edit [ __ ] you
better learn how to do a lot of these
other things because what it takes to
get into this is a lot of labor that you
probably don't want to do i met a single
[ __ ] who does this job who loves
every aspect of it it's not possible you
want to run successful automobile
company [ __ ] you better learn about
business
you might love cars but business is a
whole other ballgame and most people
don't like that even nfl players they
might love football
the business they don't always love the
fans the media they don't always love
everything comes with its share of labor
that you cannot get out of ask my sean
lynch what you don't like about i'm just
here so i don't get fined
but you know what sometimes you have to
do that so i'm just here so i just don't
get fined next question yeah that is
what marriage is sometimes i'm just here
i just don't get fired
that is what a marriage is what would
that be i'm just here to decide you want
the skittles
don't get fined
that's really
yes and i think young men young women
want to hear this kind of message i
think they understand this intrinsically
they just don't understand it's a good
thing so
yeah want to put this out and shout out
to her i really appreciate what she had
to say anything else nah man all right
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below and if you guys enjoyed
today's video leave a little like and a
little comment all right
just write comment algorithm whatever
good